on va maintenant passer à la lettre à
baba noël c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le public de ce soir il n'y a pas
pas qui m'a écrit une lettre il a écrit
une lettre
ce n'est pas renan luce je vais vous la
dire bonjour baba je me présente je
m'appelle julien j'ai trois filles
nolwenn 13 ans lola 11 ans et dylan 9
cette année a été très dure pour nous
financièrement et je ne pourrais pas
leur offrir le noël qu'elle mérite
entre la voiture qui nous lâchent toutes
les factures qui s'accumulent et mes
problèmes physiques
c'est vraiment compliqué mais fille rêve
d'avoir un pc ou une tablette pour faire
leurs devoirs d'école et je n'ai pas les
moyens de payer
je ne demande rien d'autre
car le plus important c'est que mes
filles soient heureuses en espérant que
tu liras ma lettre d' avance merci et je
le mène aux joyeux noël à vous à toute
l'équipe de tpm paix sauf mathieu
delormeau bien je vais demander à julien
et ses filles de me rejoint julien et
ses filles
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci oui pourquoi quand les gens me
voient ils appellent ça oui ok merci
d'être là bonjour l'atlas à la maman je
vous fais un gros bisou vous êtes
magnifique en tout cas toute la famille
merci mon julien d'être là tu fais quoi
dans la vie mon but je suis animateur
mais les jeux ipad seconde c'est des
gros problèmes de santé au niveau du dos
et du genou
je suis tout à fait en urgence j'ai
failli perdre ma jambe donc je travaille
mais très rarement et par papac grosse
quantité de travail ont alors j'ai fait
une demande pour vos filles m'avait
demandé des ordinateurs et des tablettes
et ben est ce qu'on peut faire entrer
notre papa noël c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pour vous ma demande et des
tablettes et des ordinateurs est ce que
vous êtes content qu'elle chérit oui tu
es content de jiri aussi ça fabien
tenait la venue près de moi on est près
de moi alors ça c'est ce que vous m'avez
demandé et j'ai enquêté un petit peu sur
vous et j'ai appris que vous aviez
beaucoup de factures ap j'ai vu j'ai
fait le calcul
et on a vu avec les équipes de
production nous avons un petit peu
enquêter on a été voir un peu votre
famille et on a vu que vous aviez pour
4200 euros de factures impayées qui vous
empêchent d'avancer
on a parlé de la banque du coeur il ya
quelques mois pas quelques jours
quelques semaines et la banque du coeur
aussi c'est donner un petit coup de
pouce et c'est un petit peu voilà le
premier fait cette banque du coeur c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a décidé de vous payer
les 4200 euros de factures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
on voudrait vraiment vous alors que vous
repartiez couvre donne ces voix-là sam
c'est un petit coup de pouce parce que
on sait que c'est difficile pour vous on
espère vous allez passer de belles fêtes
de fin d'année un beau noël et moi je le
jure
tu sais qu'on est là pour toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai offert que des tablettes mais parce
qu'il ya quand même bien je vais quand
même offrir des jouets pour les filles
quand même mais on a quand même des
petits jouets pour les filles quand même
pour noël parce qu'il ya des tablettes
c'est bien mais c'est pour bosser c'est
pour bosser c'est pas des jouets pour
les filles allez merci on a plein de
jouets pour vous en tout cas grâce à
notre partenaire hook
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut dire aux néo plane sur
chalmé